and unfortunately the violent crime this
holiday weekend extended far beyond
highland park
nearby in the city of chicago over 70
were shot and eight killed this weekend
alone and here in new york an aid to
mayor eric adams was mugged at gunpoint
in brooklyn while scouting the location
for an upcoming event
now according to the nypd shootings
soared over the 2022 july 4 weekend
compared to 2021
and over in philadelphia two officers
were shot monday night during a shooting
at a fourth of july festival but
thankfully both have been released from
the hospital but sadly the violence
plaguing major cities has become all too
common as far left leaders refused to
take the issue of violent crime
seriously and instead continued to
coddle violent offenders as cities
descend into lawlessness
here for reaction former dallas police
officer trey penny along with fox news
contributor leo terrell all right
gentlemen good evening uh you know what
we are seeing are
people out and about and i'll start with
you
leo people out and about you know fourth
of july holidays just going to barbecues
just getting shot it almost makes you
wonder if you have to think whether or
not you want to go outside leo
you're absolutely right and glad to be
on the air with your judge let me tell
you let's let's be honest
crime and murder are accepted in
democratic city how many times have i
been on shows with you judge on hannity
where every week in chicago
los angeles new york philadelphia people
are being murdered people are being
victims of crime and you know what these
are cities run by people of color
minorities hurting minorities and yet
the democratic party looks the other way
they don't cover this and we cover it on
this network but it happens every week
they accept crime they accept murder and
i'm sitting here right now on a tuesday
you know judge and i know there's going
to be more murders in new york this
weekend in chicago in philadelphia one
last point you have a mayor in
philadelphia where officers are being
shot at talking about taking away
law-abiding citizens guns and the only
people who have guns are police i got
news for you criminals will never turn
in their guns we're talking about
chicago trey we're talking about chicago
guns are illegal in chicago and yet
what's driving me crazy about this dirt
bag i don't even want to mention his
name the kid with the gun he was
homicidal he was suicidal they have a
red flag law they took 17 knives out of
his home police were at the house all
the time according to neighbors
he threatened to kill members of his
family i mean how much do you need for a
red flag law i mean 17 knives police go
and take it out of the house and a few
months later the kid gets a firearm card
and oh he's got and i haven't even
started with the social media if you
look at the social media this kid had
the stick men who were bleeding i mean
it's all there
am i wrong absolutely judge no no you're
absolutely right you're hitting it on
the nail in fact you're saying something
that a lot of the uh the liberal
networks are not really talking about
the reality is uh social media is a big
part of this i mean think about it i
mean these companies are not even
sharing information with law enforcement
we know that these indicators are out
here with these mass shooters i'm sick
of tired of these mass shootings
happening in the united states but the
reality is these social media companies
they see this content on their platform
and they're not sharing it with law
enforcement so we can talk all day long
about being reactionary and and what
what what signs we missed as a law
enforcement at law enforcement agencies
but the bottom line is if we don't get
the information before the the attack
occurs then there's no way that we can
we can intervene to stop the attacks
from even happening uh we're simply
tired of and with that in mind judge i
want to make sure i remind people as a
president of the national fallen altar
foundation i want to remind people that
we are coming up on the sixth
anniversary of the mass shooting attack
in dallas texas that claims allowed the
five police officers we want to make
sure that we do remind people of that
well not only reminding people of that
but you know what in this crazy world
leo you've got police officers and if
they didn't see what was happening at
that fourth of july parade in highland
park you got the cops running in there
you see the swat team you see them on
their trucks you see them all suited up
and you say thank god it's america the
cavalry's coming and these people on the
left they want to damn the cops they
want to damn the police they want to
take away their ability to fight
criminals they want to let the criminals
out of jail what is going on leo
uh a democrats control of the white
house democratic control of congress
judge two three years ago defunded
police is still alive and well and these
same democratic leaders they got private
security they're swamped with private
security but they don't want to protect
law enforcement never in my lifetime
historically have officers been under
attack and less supported in these
cities one final point the prosecutors
democratic prosecutor these metropolitan
cities their soft crime criminals are
happy to live in democratic cities
they're not soft on crime trade the
truth is they want the criminals out and
about they want to let them out of
prison and i love you leo i mean and i
mean that i mean i'm agreeing with you
the truth is they want to let them out
god bless the criminals give them a
break and it's just it's for someone who
was a d.a it infuriates me it is what we
don't need we ought to thank every cop
we see trey last last word to you that's
that's right look but look judge there's
an 83 percent increase of uh of the of
the recidivism rate amongst the violent
offenders that are released from prison
we have to do more to lock these people
up if you look in 2012 obama shut down
all the private prisons that we have so
they use this argument of our prisons
are crowded they're crowded they're
crowded the bottom line is we need to
start reopening our prisons get up get
uh get get these violent offenders off
the streets and lock these people up so
we can keep our communities safe
we have to do something
thanks guys leo and trey thanks for
being with us today hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else